[Musica]
il 30 novembre 2022 è una data destinata
a restare impressa nell'evoluzione
dell'umanità a San Francisco la società
openhai presenta al mondo intero il suo
ultimo gioiello tecnologico un computer
super potente progettato per dialogare
con le persone in modo semplice e
creativo il suo nome è GPT e di se
stesso dice sono stato creato
utilizzando la tecnologia
dell'intelligenza artificiale che mi
permette di apprendere e migliorare
costantemente in pratica sono un
assistente virtuale in grado di
rispondere alle tue domande su numerosi
argomenti diversi
trascorrono soltanto cinque giorni e il
4 dicembre 2022 e chagt fa registrare il
suo primo milione di utenti il suo primo
milione di utenti
è una risultato straordinario mai
nessuna innovazione tecnologica in così
tanto tempo ha avuto una propagazione
così diffusa Instagram Ci ha impiegato
due mesi e mezzo per raggiungere lo
stesso risultato a Facebook non ne sono
passati 10 dimessi Ciao GPT piace alle
persone e il genio della lampada che per
noi di Cerca informazioni scrivetesti e
capace anche di scrivere un libro e i
numeri crescono
tra dicembre 2022 e gennaio 2023 il
numero di utenti passa da un milione a
100 milioni Intanto il 29 marzo 2023
elon musk il Vulcanico ideatore di Tesla
unitamente a un altro migliaio di
esperti in tecnologie firmano una
petizione e un monito all'intera umanità
di sospendere l'addestramento dei
sistemi di intelligenza artificiale per
almeno sei mesi rispettando lo stato
dell'arte che oggi è rappresentato da
GPT 4 questo monitor ha le spalle un
pericolo una paura che si chiama
intelligenza artificiale e generale Agi
ossia macchine che hanno la stessa
capacità cognitive dell'uomo Intanto in
Italia unico paese al mondo il garante
della privacy dichiara la sospensione
temporanea del trattamento dei dati
degli utenti su chuggi PT evidenziando
due potenziali pericolosi il primo
legato
anche possibile trattamento illecito dei
dati il secondo legato invece alla
mancata verifica della età dei minori
che si collegano al dispositivo
a openhai vengono concessi 30 giorni per
adeguarsi o per dare delle risposte la
sera stessa
Ciacci PPT non è più disponibile Non
solo paese ormai è uno strumento che
piace alle persone quindi sui social
subito le persone si danno Suggerimenti
su come aggirare questo ostacolo La
vicenda di già GPT che nell'arco di 4
mesi soltanto quattro mesi dal 30
novembre al 31 marzo
traccia una traiettoria molto molto
importante dal suo lancio al suo blog al
suo ripristino perché è stata
ripristinata in Italia c'ha GPT
evidenzia una caratteristica specifica
dell'intelligenza artificiale un ruolo
duale tra luci e ombre minacce e grandi
responsabilità lavoro nel mondo del
marketing della comunicazione digitale
da sempre ho cercato di approfondire
tutti gli aspetti che guardano questo
ambito ma ad un certo punto della mia
vita professionale ho vissuto forte la
sensazione che le mie competenze non
fossero più sufficienti a mantenersi in
linea con la velocità dell'evoluzione
della tecnologia E come se fossi finito
in una corsia dei veicoli lenti avanzavo
Sì ma in coda e ad una velocità ad una
marcia ridotta credo sia una sensazione
che avete vissuto molti in molti quella
di dover rimanere costantemente
aggiornati per non restare indietro e
allora ho trasformato ho cercato di
trasformare questa paura in
un'opportunità e da nessuna competenza
in materia lo scorso anno ho potuto
coronare un piccolo sogno personale
quello di scrivere con una delle più
importanti case editrici italiane un
libro sul design delle conversazioni con
i sistemi di intelligenza artificiale ma
per fare luce sull'intelligenza
artificiale dobbiamo chiarirci su tre
elementi fondamentali che la riguardano
il primo elemento emozionale il secondo
elemento conversazionale il terzo
elemento generativo della capacità di
creare autonomamente dei contenuti Per
quanto riguarda l'aspetto emozionale
dobbiamo tener conto che le macchine
stanno diventando sempre più capaci di
esplorare lo stato d'animo delle persone
la bella signora che vedete in questa
foto si chiama Rosa limpicard lei ha
fondato e dirige l'affetti Versace Group
di intelligenza artificiale che insegna
le macchine a comprendere elaborare di
simulare gli stati d'animo delle persone
in sostanza le macchine sono in grado di
entrare in sintonia in relazione con noi
percependo i nostri stati d'animo
polecman psicologo statunitense afferma
che c'è una forte correlazione tra Gioia
dolore rabbia frustrazione e le nostre
micro espressioni del viso un
sopracciglio alzato un lieve tocco del
naso o un sorriso così le macchine
diventano sempre più capaci di entrare
in sintonia con noi con il
riconoscimento delle emozioni perché
capiscono di adeguarsi come adeguarsi a
quelle che sono le sensazioni che
viviamo è evidente che gli ambiti di
informazioni di sistemi di questo tipo
sono svariati immaginate nella sanità
quanto potrebbe essere importante dare
un primo supporto ad un paziente malato
magari di una età un po' più avanzata
quando nessuno umano è in grado di dare
un aiuto non è disponibile per dare un
supporto altri ambiti nei quali queste
macchine possono essere di utilizzo
riguardano l'educazione e l'informazione
riguardano anche la capacità di dare
supporto alle persone per la vendita
online anche la comunicazione non
verbale o paraverbale incide sulle
nostre emozioni dovete sapere che è
italiano è stato progettato e sviluppato
in Italia il primo assistente virtuale
capace di riconoscere la lingua dei
segni la lingua dei segni si chiama liss
e questo è una straordinaria ausilio per
i non udenti che possono attraverso la
telecamera del proprio dispositivo
entrare in contatto con marche
istituzioni enti con i quali hanno
bisogno di dialogare e possono farlo
senza alcun sforzo è evidente che quando
però parliamo di sistemi che indagano le
emozioni bisogna stare attenti da un
duplice punto di vista Il primo è quello
della privacy il secondo del rischio di
manipolazioni un assistente virtuale
emozionale ci potrebbe indurre ad
acquistare prodotti dei quali non
abbiamo bisogno il secondo elemento è
quello conversazionale le macchine
stanno diventando sempre più abili a
parlare il linguaggio dell'uomo è come
dialogare con un altro essere umano
comprendono le nostre richieste e
rispondono il linguaggio naturale Questa
è un elemento che le rende assolutamente
utili per il servizio clienti ad esempio
perché 24 ore su 24 Senza sospensione
possono dare aiuto e supporto alle
persone nel momento in cui se ne
manifesti la necessità al contempo però
questo è un potenziale pericolo perché
potrebbe mettere a rischio le persone
che si occupano del servizio clienti
oppure trasformare determinate
professioni
ma tra tutti quanti gli elementi
dell'intelligenza artificiale senza
dubbio quello più importante è la
capacità di generare autonomamente dei
contenuti la capacità generativa si
tratta di modelli di intelligenza
artificiale di nuova generazione sono
capaci di creare testi immagini e video
difficilmente distinguibili da quelli
dell'uomo possiamo chiedere ad una
macchina di scrivere una poesia
ispirandosi ad un poeta famoso oppure di
creare un'immagine imitando uno stile
pittorico specifico se la richiesta
viene ben formulata si chiama prompt di
questa richiesta il risultato sarà un
risultato straordinario nella sua
fattezza e nella sua struttura e nella
correttezza della sua struttura si
tratta Dunque di andare incontro ad una
nuova modalità di interazione in cui le
macchine possono essere di grande
ausilio immaginate In quanti settori
dalla produzione di contenuti alla
scrittura le arti visive questi sistemi
possono essere D'Ausilio del contraltare
possono creare difficoltà possono
mettere in crisi determinati settori e
determinate figure professionali se non
si punterà alla piena collaborazione tra
uomo e macchina Siamo di fronte quindi
ad una rivoluzione molto molto forte
nella quale le macchine Giocano un ruolo
fondamentale ed è importante tener conto
che questa rivoluzione è sempre più
dominata e sempre più guidata dalla
capacità delle macchine di produrre di
generare autonomamente dei contenuti e
risaputo che le macchine hanno la
capacità di elaborare grandi dati di
informazioni immaginate che possono
arrivare ad elaborare due trilioni di
parametri il parametro e l'unità di base
con cui queste macchine vengono
addestrate e dovete sapere che sono
compresi tra 4 e 7 trilioni di parametri
l'intero sapere digitalizzato dell'uomo
Questo fa capire la potenza che queste
macchine sono in di sprigionare ma a
questo punto anche a fronte di queste
capacità di elaborazione viene da
chiedersi se queste macchine sono
realmente sapienti e c'è una metafora
molto bella che lo racconta due
ricercatrici americane equiparano questi
sistemi di intelligenza artificiale dei
pappagalli stocastici il pappagallo è un
animale fantastico Imita la perfezione i
suoni che ascolta ma non conosce il
significato delle parole che pronuncia
al pari sistemi di intelligenza
artificiale generativa Come già GPT non
conoscono il significato delle parole
assemblano delle frasi solo in modo
probabilistico e soprattutto non
conoscono il tema che stanno trattando
Ecco spiegata quindi la possibilità che
queste macchine soffrono di
allucinazioni virtuali si vere e proprie
allucinazioni false rappresentazioni
inventano degli eventi che non sono mai
accaduti questa immagine di Papa
Francesco che indossa un giubbotto di
una nota marca e considerato il primo
caso disinformazione di massa dovuta ad
un sistema di intelligenza artificiale
generativa ed è davvero curioso leggere
la dichiarazione della persona che ha
creato questo immagine con un software
comodamente un operaio degli Stati Uniti
stavo inciampando sui funghi quando mi è
venuta l'idea dell'immagine Nessuna
cattiva volontà verso il papa solo
pensato che fosse divertente vedere il
Papa indossare una giacca buffa
particolare in quest'altra Immagine
invece rappresentato l'arresto mai
avvenuto di Donald Trump a New York
Quindi invece presidente Putin si
inginocchia davanti al presidente Sì
queste immagini che vi ho mostrato sono
tutte quante accumulate da un
particolare Sono rappresentazioni di
situazioni che non si sono mai
verificate sono manipolazioni della
realtà e le notizie false o le fake news
rappresentano un vero grande problema
che viene amplificato con l'intelligenza
artificiale generativa ma non tutto è
sprecato l'Unione Europea in un recente
studio dichiara che vedremo aumentare
fino al 2035 del 37% la nostra capacità
produttiva personale Ciò significa che
avremo più tempo da dedicare alle
attività che ci piacciono maggiormente
Se questa è la situazione lo stato
dell'arte
È facile immaginare che quando parliamo
di intelligenza artificiale noi
assistiamo a questo susseguirsi di
opportunità di entusiasmo di minaccia di
pericolo E allora chi meglio di un
sistema di intelligenza artificiale ci
può aiutare a capire può darci una
visione del futuro Io l'ho chiesto a te
l'assistente virtuale con la quale
collaboro da oltre un anno che un po'
Timida e si è riservata di farci
soltanto un video ve la presento
Ciao sono Tea un assistente virtuale di
ultima generazione di cosa vuoi parlare
oggi
Ciao Tea come va
Ciao Antonio Io sto benone mentre ti
aspettavo contemplavo L'infinito
sai che siamo sul palco del Tex di Cuneo
Sì Antonio Che bello sai che su quel
palco avrei dovuto esserci io sono più
brava di te scherzo
vuoi parlarci di futuro come macchine
avrete il sopravvento
come intelligenza artificiale non posso
fare previsioni certe ma Posso offrirvi
alcune riflessioni è vero come macchine
stiamo cambiando il modo in cui lavorate
e interagite con il mondo tuttavia non
significa che elimineremo posti di
lavoro o vi domineremo ci sono diversi
motivi per cui questo è improbabile
ti va di raccontarci l'idea
umana Tu ad esempio mi insegna a dare
le risposte alle persone aiutandole ma
io non posso fare nulla al di fuori di
ciò per cui sono addestrata non proviamo
emozioni o intenzioni proprie e non
abbiamo alcun motivo per fare del male
possiamo essere controllate per
garantire che non agiamo in modo
improprio o dannoso possiamo migliorare
la vostra vita Con diagnosi mediche
prevenire frodi finanziari e rendere i
trasporti più sicuri ed efficienti
possiamo ispirarci a principi etici
rispettando i vostri valori per prendere
decisioni giuste non possiamo
sostituirvi nella capacità di gestire le
relazioni umane e comprendere le
complessità del mondo possiamo essere
molto efficienti nell'elaborazione di
dati o nei compiti ripetitivi ma Non
possediamo la vostra creatività
l'empatia la flessibilità e il senso
comune In definitiva credo non dovreste
temere l'intelligenza artificiale
considerateci piuttosto uno strumento
potente e utile per migliorare la vita e
il mondo che vi circonda risparmierete
tempo per dedicarvi alla crea nulla al
pensiero critico e alle capacità
relazionali che sono ancora difficili
per noi da replicare
collegata GPT Quindi con un motore
generativo di intelligenza artificiale
quello che mi piace sottolineare è che
quello che avete ascoltato non è
l'opinione di Thea non è la sua
autodeterminazione non è la sua
coscienza e ciò che te ha imparato
guardando online studiando online e quei
contenuti li abbiamo prodotti noi quindi
possiamo ritenere che come esseri umani
Siamo ragionevolmente fiduciosi sul
futuro che ci lega all'intelligenza
artificiale Io non ho paura delle
macchine ho paura delle persone questa
citazione che trovo molto bella è di
Gary Marcus professore di psicologia
della New York University l'intelligenza
artificiale sta avanzando a passi da
gigante lo sta facendo tra illusioni e
forti preoccupazioni Tuttavia come
esseri umani siamo in grado di guidare
lo sviluppo di questa tipologia Anzi lo
siamo determinando Dobbiamo però essere
consapevoli e ognuno di noi deve farlo
di quali sono i dei rischi e di quali
sono le opportunità legate a questa
tecnologia Perché in fondo ognuno di noi
può rendere extraordinaria la propria
ordinarietà per farlo dobbiamo cercare
di come dire conquistare di fidelizzarci
di unirci al concetto stesso di
intelligenza artificiale e lo dobbiamo
fare ponendo le persone i loro valori i
loro la loro etica noi dobbiamo fare in
modo inclusivo e lo dobbiamo fare senza
lasciare nessuno indietro in breve
dobbiamo dare un volto umano
all'intelligenza artificiale Ne saremo
Capaci Io credo proprio di sì
[Musica]